pourquoi vous la vendez toujours et tire
une cas
on avait dit 9001 je règle tout en une
fois vous savez monsieur qu'acheter la
cave à cette nuit là dormi en bas tous
les jours y vient dans les toilettes me
suis dit rien et d'un coup ils hurlent
ils traitent de sales [ __ ] m
j'annule la vente de cette cape où vous
allez nous ramener clic non la cave elle
est à moi vous avez encaissé le chèque
je rentre chez moi puis voulu pour rien
ce type est un négationniste qui nie les
camps de la mort nazis tu m'as jamais
dit qu'on habitait l'appartement de tous
les déportés
tu dis rien tu demande de l'aide à
personne on est frères [ __ ] je sais
que j'aurai du temps parler se font hic
c'est un pervers il va établir son
emprise moi je me contente pas rabâcher
la vérité officielle je suis un
chercheur insomniaques fais
tu nous promet que tu ne lui parlera pu
moi c'est fini je mets plus les pieds
hors la gav le seule chose qui compte
justin ce que tu as freineur pensée pour
toi même tu sais juste que poser des
questions des questions qui dérangent la
vérité officielle vous avez peur de quoi
la vérité
sentir votre peur sait ce qui l'attend
mais simon était rendu compte qu'il
aurait pu s'en prendre à être
il semblerait que vous n'êtes pas
propriétaire de votre appartement
comment ils dérangent postés
pas pourquoi on s'acharne contre lui oh
tu comprends pas qu'il faut en finir
on prend les choses en main qu'il
casserait la gueule à cette pourriture
tu t'es revenu j'espère quoi
ils essayent de l'excellent on est
ensemble on s'aime
[Musique]